hello testing testing this is a very
official testing of my microphone before
I get into this game
I hope I have everything balanced
perfectly because I'm a professional
YouTuber and content creator and gamer
of the Year officially hello hi hello
welcome one second one second
one moment everything is fine don't
worry about a thing everything is okay
don't panic stop panicking everything's
good
everything's good welcome one and all to
choo choo Charles the game about a
haunted train stalking you in the woods
if I make this sound any more dramatic
then oh God I didn't change the name no
oh man of all the things
oh God now the notification that went
out but no one's gonna know that it's
choo choo Charles
no
no oh I thought I had everything
perfectly
I thought I had everything perfectly
ah
I was so close to Glory
I was so close to perfection
listen the reason it's such a problem is
that I am gamer of the Year whatever I
say in terms of games goes for an entire
year I am the decision maker on all
gaming related decisions
that burden is on me and now officially
in Forever choo choo Charles is no
longer choo choo Charles it's getting
over it
oh man all right well
I'm sure steam will get to that and um
everything will be 100 okay
[Music]
I already beat getting over it again I'm
not going for the 50 getting over
training over it
yeah Charles is over it yeah look it's
it's not click bait people would want to
see Choo-Choo Charles more than they
would want to see getting over it I
would think because it's newer and it's
choo choo tour
I don't know ever guys look listen
I'm gamer of the year but you know what
I'm not
I'm not an Emmy Award winner
[Music]
I went to the Emmys last night
and I'm so sad to say
that we didn't get the Emmy
we did it sounds like I'm laughing but
I'm crying
we didn't get it guys
we lost
we lost the Emmy
we lost it
we lost it
and you know what's even worse
an Emmy loser
yeah that's me Markiplier
Emmy Award losing creator
yep
ah man you know it's funny and this is
gonna this is gonna sound us very
strange
um because it paints a view into a world
let me know that music might be a little
love it paints a view into a world that
I am very unfamiliar with well actually
I'm very familiar with it but I choose
to ignore it very much so just like I
choose to ignore a lot of the things
that come along with
um being in the public eye sometimes uh
so I go to the Emmys right and there's a
red carpet and let me let me be
perfectly honest like I was I was
honored to go there but as far as events
that I've gone to this was one of the
more underwhelming events
um and it's kind of that preconceived
notion where you think that things like
and and is gonna sound disparaging to
the Emmys it's not it's just what it was
and what I would compare it to to other
things that I have gone to
um it was extremely underwhelming
and the thing is the thing is I hate red
carpets right I hate look I'll get to
the game in a second you want me to Play
It Again I get to talk about my
experiences of losing an enemy this is
my stream you shut up and you sit down
I'm gamer of the year I might be Emmy
losing winner not being a winner person
but you sit down and you listen to me
talking about my story
anyway the carpet wasn't even red
it was purple and I was like Liz this
isn't even right this isn't even right
so anyway so um I hate red carpets in
general red carpet is just a blanket
sweep term for it's an opportunity for
all these Publications to take pictures
of you
and so it sounds all fancy and you you
know a lot of people probably look at
that wow that's great it's really boring
and it's really awkward and it's really
weird it's a super and I was like do I
have to do it they were like you're
nominated of course you have to do it
I'm like why do I have to do it he's
like why wouldn't you want to do it and
I'm like I have no desire to do that
um and it was like no you're nominated
you gotta do it and so I did it and
what's fascinating to me what's
fascinating to me is that even six years
ago and the last time that I did a red
carpet which was not my I did not
volunteer to do it and I hate doing it
it's just so pompous and and oh it's
stupid is back then I would I was
perfectly understanding that I was at a
movie premiere and like no one knew who
the [ __ ] I was and I didn't care about
anyway it's whatever
so this one I was nominated right I'm
nominated for an awarded there and all
of the Publications there still didn't
give a [ __ ] who I was and this is fine
it's not a moment where I'm like do you
know who I am what amazes me
is that if any of them were to interview
me and put those videos on YouTube they
would do exceptionally well for their
channels when I appear in I've done like
wired interviews and I've done like
things like that those videos do well
and I'm happy to do them because I'm
always happy to talk about anything
because I love to talk I love talking I
love talk blah blabbing and you love
listen me talk you love me listen me
talk do because I hold you Hostage to
watch this fun fun game you want choo
choo Charles you listen to me talk
because I love talk and I keep talk
until you listen and when you listen
that I play but I play later but I'm
going to play when I after I talk
and so it's one of those hilarious
things where it's not that I'm offended
right because I don't care I don't want
to be there in the first place but it
amazes me it amazes me because they
didn't just not know who I was they
actively didn't want to talk to me and
it's this world where YouTubers and the
traditional uh entertainment business
are not in sync with each other they are
adamantly opposed they don't not know
who I am because if they didn't know who
I am and they choose to uh not interview
me that's one thing I understand that
that's perfectly fine
but I was nominated at this event and
therefore they if they're good at their
job would know who I am and then they
would know the value of talking to me
and getting a video of me on their
Channel and yet they don't and it goes
to show that there is still a
fundamental disconnect in the world from
YouTube content creators
and the Hollywood and TV and whatever
and it's a world that I don't want to be
part of and I think that I actively
don't want to be part of it and that's
what makes this animosity kind of
pervasive because they realize that I
and none of my fellow content creators
need them
in any way
and the moment that they acknowledge
that reality that everything just kind
of falls apart for them and it's really
hilarious
it's really interesting no I'm not mad
because it's fascinating right I'm not
losing anything I'm not losing anything
from not talking to them because I don't
gain anything from talking to them a lot
of people think of Publications as a
thing like oh it's exposure it's like oh
it's good for you there's no exposure
that could even remotely compare to what
I'm able to do on YouTube and what so
many other content creators are able to
do on YouTube and whenever I get a view
into this world of like that traditional
entertainment business I step back and I
go like oh my God
I have it so much better
here on YouTube when I'm able to hold my
audience hostage I'm able to grab them
by the Scruff of the throat and I'm able
to just choke the life out of them and
I'm like I'll play that game when I feel
like it you want your tutorial so bad
don't you but you want it as bad as you
want to breathe and that's when you get
to play I'm gonna play now
that is what I do in these streams you
know I do just hold you don't
I know it's been a while since we last
don't make it like that but something
something is typing supervising
no trust me
make time
for something big to keep your Museum in
business
well there's something big on that
island real big
so many friends and even my own son are
still out there if anyone can bring this
thing down it's you it'll be the biggest
attraction your city's ever seen and you
can help an old friend yes meet me on
the docks Sunset I hope you're ready for
a little Monster Hunt
I am ready for a little Monster hunting
indeed
are you ready to choo choo
are you ready everyone at all
and I'll kill a train we're gonna go
kill a train whatever that means also
it's one of those things where I would
have so much rather
from Hell half what
wow
just a few people to meet places you
know
era what
we're making their own grades stay close
Charles isn't the only thing to fear
around here what what do you mean
what does that mean what do you mean
what do you mean
what
we
oh no all right okay yeah the resolution
is messed up hold on
hold on
look I got a new computer and I'm still
making sure all the settings are good
and I just want you to know that I want
everything to be perfectly perfect at
all times
and so
I appreciate your patience
in this endeavor
is that better
all right cool
man
why are you flashing so hard
let's see smaller
smaller
smaller
all right there we go
skip tip
hello
is this interactable I can't tell is it
glowing what's glowing
operators
so his old engine should be in there
what do you mean guys it's not it's not
good this is not good
defensible tool on our journey on our
journey okay wait hold on wait a minute
I know what the problem is I know the
problem is
right right right okay
let's just
let's just do this here
all right so I got this and then we're
gonna put that there
and there we go all right Perfect all
right everybody
all right here we go guys
[Laughter]
oh sorry this shouldn't I I don't know
I'm laughing sword I'm never gonna be
able to get this back let's see is there
undo in there is there is there is there
is there is there is there's there's
there's there's
and
bam
all right we're good
holy crap Eugene come back
oh my God that old man can move
Eugene
Eugene
oh my God he's in a hurry he's trying to
get ahead of the gameplay because I've
been taking so damn long all right
Eugene I'm on the way you hold on
and I'm coming Eugene
Eugene I'm coming
[Laughter]
all right where did he go
God damn he was so fast
all right oh there he is standing like a
weirdo Hey Eugene how you doing
just trying to get a good look at you
cool
looking good there why are you flashing
what's wrong with your skin you okay
there bud you all right gotta watch out
for Charles he might be sneaking up
behind you
oh God
oh not to worry we can still find a way
in okay there's a small shack up the
path that might have a key inside okay
take this map I just marked the location
on it okay see if the key is up there
and I'll look around some more down here
okay
I didn't get any of that whoa
baby's first mission
why does that sound so derogatory
and look inside the nearby Shack for the
key to the train station okay
you got it pat oh my God you got it pal
I'm going
I'm going pal
don't worry about a thing definitely
don't die to know choo choo Charles
squonk
oh you still there Eugene you still
there is you still there
is you still there what a weird key
turn up the game will you may turn up
the game The Game's fine
the game's fine isn't it fine
it's fine
sound
can you not hear anything
oh no
what's the truth what is the truth what
is the truth I don't know what the truth
is I don't know what the truth is what's
the truth is this better
I'm gonna go with this I want you to
have a great experience I'm gamer of the
year I need to set an example for
everybody I need to set it good on you
on you looks like you found it open up
that door and Lead the Way
is that better if it seems loud now it
seems loud not now it seems now it's
it's too loud God damn it
I don't know I don't know is it
good okay all right
all right good it's loud oh man I don't
know I want you to have a good
experience
I want this to be a perfectly good
experience for everybody involved but I
just can't oh hey
I don't like that it's called Charles
I don't like that at all
use it quickly your epic train use it to
quickly navigate the island a weapon a
shield against your foes your respawn
point if things go wrong interact with
items around them to learn to use it oh
well
well that seems pretty cool oh my god
oh yes
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh yeah
is that loud is that good that's good
isn't it too loud
volume is perfect it's perfect hi well
the exterior is a little rough but
everything looks to be intact yeah hell
yeah that gun you were looking at wasn't
on here when I was evacuated from the
island but it sure looks fun to use yeah
it does
we can light up Charles with it and take
him down before he even sees us coming
I will do that thank you are you ready
to take this thing for a spin yes
it's like it's weird right so his
dialogue that's what's weird about it
his dialogue all right we're gonna nail
this
because his dialogue needs to be louder
but the sound effects need to be quieter
because the guns were a little loud so I
need to crank up the volume on my mixer
keep it at 150 percent so that the
voices get louder but the sound effects
get a little quieter and then we're
gonna torch the music down just a bit to
keep the Ambiance there but not get in
the way of anything important this is
the perfect mix everybody now I've got
it I'm Tula I'm too loud
I'm I'm too yeah
there are subtitles subtitles are
currently on
how can you not see the subtitles
they're there see watch this see now the
Ambiance is tickling the back of your
eardrums in this clean loud but not
overbearing right
right
there are so subtitles
there are subtitles
no not on my voice this is a live stream
what do you mean how could I the
subtitles are too loud I don't even
understand what you're talking about
don't you want to see the game or do you
want me to spend the entire time messing
with the audio
how am I gonna get to the game if I I
can't even get to the audio good thing I
got a new damn air conditioner in here I
wouldn't otherwise I'd be sweltering
with rage from all of you [ __ ]
trying to tell me how to audio I'm gamer
of the year
I'm an Emmy Award losing creator
okay all right I'm going
perfect
oh baby
and coming for you Charles yeah
wait wait
what are you doing
[Music]
dude
Eugene
you didn't know
no no
oh my God
this isn't how things were supposed to
end I thought we could still fight like
the old days
yes sir
Ian
easy out you'll need to do more than I
thought
I don't have time to
do
eggs
fine
man
if only the subtitles were on Eugene
maybe you could have seen that comment
you did
you did I loved you
you were like it
I'm cool to me
you were there remember when you called
me in the fall boots
World sprinting champion
should be uphill of it oh my God
oh my God
anyway
all right we're over it no more crying
over Eugene I don't want to hear a peep
about Eugene we're over it we never
looked to the past we look to the Future
and the future is looking bright for us
we gotta train and we're on our Lonesome
let's get out of here what am I doing I
don't even know what the hell I'm
supposed to do
like
oh
unmet NPC there are other people here
this place is huge
oh this place is huge
oh no it's huge
oh no
oh no guys it's huge
all right guys we're on it it's choo
choo Charles time we're gonna Charles
Hard
what happens if I jump off the train
when it's moving can I oh no no no no no
no no no no no no okay we're okay it
stops okay
okay we're okay we're okay
we're okay we're okay don't look note to
self don't do that note to self don't do
it rail switching huh rail switching
okay we're going left is that where we
want to go
uh yeah let's go left why not
all right
I know I know guys but I don't want to
hear a thing no Eugene is not too loud
Eugene is dead
Eugene is dead and we'll never see
Eugene again
I don't want to hear a peep about Eugene
I don't want to hear anything about
Eugene still being heard
Eugene's dead
and that's okay
hello
hi
who the hell are you how are you alive
out here you must be the archivers that
Eugene told us about
it yeah well Eugene's dead don't you
talk about Eugene anymore we're happy
that came to help us out of this
predicament with Charles and that madman
Warren Warren
you know where the old trainiors would
need some major upgrades if you want to
take down Charles
there are some metal scraps in my bar
unless you could use to improve it
here's the key of the bar it's just at
the path but I'll mark it on your map
anyway
okay all right thanks
um all right is this Baby's second
mission thank you please never talk
about Eugene ever again
I don't want to hear about them
yeah just like Ohio yeah I turned the
contrast down
it's within title I don't think it do
that ain't right you ain't right nothing
about you is right oh there's a lot of
crap in here
thank you for the scrap sir good for you
to trust me
it's awfully kind of you
are sure hope there aren't any bodies in
here maybe Tony Tittle was dead all
alone
even though Eugene has promised to send
help once he reaches the mainland I've
just realized he'd never mentioned if
he'd return I suppose he is the type of
person to ignore the fine details of a
plan everyone on the island is trying to
find a way out of this mess and I can
only hope that this archivist friend of
his can work some magic I don't care
what strange things they've done before
or what practices they use as long as
Charles ends up dead most folks around
here want the same but then there are
those crazies that want to leave and be
that Don Warren has lost his marbles
anyway
I feel like I did a pretty good
impression there but none of you would
agree with that because you're too busy
being sassy to even pay attention to the
art that I'm putting into this do you
know how difficult it is how much vocal
control I have to have to be able to
match that so perfectly and yet you were
all glossing over it about like the
letters too loud oh the lights are too
loud oh the hair in my mouth is too loud
is that really all you can think about
yeah whatever they there we go yeah
yeah thank you yeah thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much uh do I
need to talk to you anymore are you
still alive did you mysteriously die how
are you still alive out here you don't
even want to talk to me anymore you're
up
don't lean back anymore
don't lean back where am I you'll never
know where I am
what are you looking at me like that
are you looking at me like that
pucker in your lips
oh okay
all right so
I'm thinking that I can upgrade now
maximum forward all weapon damage all
damage
well I got nine let's go do one of each
right
be the most efficient right all right
we're going
where am I going next Who's Warren
who is Warren I want to go uh there's a
bunch of people over here that I haven't
met
red I don't know if that's good or bad
all right we're going on choo choo
Charles doesn't seem to be around here
so I guess we're fine
I don't know if it's like only scripted
when he comes out or if he's actually
roaming around and I need to worry about
that
beautiful landscape
here in the wonderful Plains of Ohio
gorgeous really if you think about it
but don't think about it too hard you'd
strain your tiny brain cells I think I'm
here
right here yeah
squeak what is that
is this important
whoa whoa a bonanza hello
have you seen a train
please don't mention Eugene
I don't want to hear about anyone
starting with the letter e at all hi
is that what we're doing here hey don't
mind me hey
okay
interesting
[Music]
pickles locked away inside my pickle
cave
okay
all right
come on
I mean lock picks and if you can bring
me my special jar of pickles
okay
all right
well you do look like you have a lot of
scrap metal in there um
apparently I can just take it
I'm not going to do this as an
impression pickles are love
pickles are life I love the pickles they
make me feel happiness pickles pickles
pickles
all right I'm just gonna all right it's
probably locked away in there right all
right I'm taking this anyway uh
see you later
you enjoy yourself okay so what there
was um
someone with a lock pick and then there
was a pickle key or something like that
or I gotta go to a cave and then
it's there yeah something like that oh
yeah I know uh I did start the only fans
I do it
let me guess this is too loud for you
before
oh
what I hear something
[Music]
you hear that
what is that
what is that
what is that
what is that
what is that
you hear that
can't tell where it is
is that him
is that Juju Charles
is that Charles
that's Charles
oh I'm in trouble wait I don't want to
go dorms I'm
wait I don't want to go towards him but
what am I doing oh what am I doing okay
this is gonna go left uh okay left I can
Circle back new what oh the pickle right
all right yeah we don't want to go that
way
let's not go that way
okay we got another PC over there
okay we're fine all right eight scraps
uh
speak yeah
okay
we're okay so long as we don't get in
trouble
all right we're coming up on this place
here whatever this is from that train
station
okay
hello
someone here
anybody
I don't know how much time I have before
Charles appears
but uh
gonna take your scrap
okay
hello
hello
welcome to aramiram archivist Museum
person uh-huh my apologies I'm not the
best with introductions but I don't
believe either of us are here for
socializing but what are you doing here
uh
uh Theodore it just so happened to have
a little business opportunity if you're
interested man capitalism
little box of mine is in a rail car in
the nearby Canyon but the goons have set
up a camp to protect that area so be
careful
lagoons find the blue box and bring it
back to me I'll give you some scraps as
payment ah good scraps that's what I
want thank you definitely not money
before the cave-in I pushed a spare rail
car into the canyon using my beautiful
old mining train I figured a rail car
would be a fine place to hide my more
important belongings especially on a
rural and unfinished track I went to get
something out of my rail car in the
canyon about a week ago but some of
Warrens men's built a campsite a base of
some sort of there I don't know how to
get my box safely and I don't know how
long I'll last without it
I don't know why that went in there
that was weird actually that was
perfectly normal I think we were worried
about that everybody shut up
white great
I like yellow
oh my bones why did that hurt so badly
it was barely a fall
I'm fine lasago
no
yellow thank you all right so I don't
know where he whoa there oh that well
that's that's totally nearby wait a
minute
wait that's right nearby
I'm just going to go for it then
huh
probably fine
is it a good thing to be able to uh
be this far away from my train am I
gonna be okay
um
am I gonna be all right
what what pot what huh what what what
what what wow oh why would you do that
die die I'm dead what
oh boy what
what
okay the answer to that question is
you're not okay uh
I love the hey
thank you thank you for that thank you
appreciate that appreciate big preach
all right get my weapon damage up I
guess
maybe I can shoot them from a distance
where am I all right
that's a weird
that's a big place all right
what is that supposed to be
hello
were you think there were any uh scrap
metal in here that I didn't get I bet
there was
I thought there was a ton
probably because I didn't even know to
get scrap metal just yet
but I bet there is
oh
oh oh oh oh oh go backwards
oh wait a minute
wait a minute how do I shoot him if he's
in front of me
wait a minute
wait a minute what do I do what do I do
what do I do what do I do
what
what oh what do I do what do I do what
do I do
I don't know what do I do wow
what do I do
[Music]
use my can I point it around to the
front
can I point it around to the front can I
do that
oh
well that's handy all right
I don't know how that works but uh
I'm just gonna assume that that's gonna
be okay I have no scraps even to repair
where am I ah all right
let's just carry on and hope that he
doesn't show up again
because uh
I don't have any scraps left so I don't
know if this is gonna take my life and
game over me or what
and also my train is in bad shape so I
need I need some scraps
for sure
don't honk whistle the tracks Charles
okay understood
understood everybody understood but it's
so tempting oh but it's so tempting
it's so is it like a mating cult well it
couldn't possibly be a mating call
because it's like
murder
maybe I don't know what do I know about
train mating
man my train is either going really slow
because it's terrible
reports damaged let me check in here I
didn't actually get to look upstairs
before I heard something horrible on the
horizon
let me see again
that door is locked why I don't know
nothing up here why I don't know can I
jump out the window no why I don't know
all right so there was oh oh my bones
there's nothing here
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
back this way
I don't have a lock pick and I probably
die so I'm going to go over here and I'm
gonna check out these guys here because
this seems like an interesting open area
and hopefully I can get some more scrap
and then oh wait that said a weapon
Mission maybe I can get a gun
that'd be dope if only I could get any
sort of speed going
huh
also why
says Charles
Charles Mining Company
why
[Music]
this game would be so fun multiplayer
this game would be the best if I could
play this with Bob and Wade I know I
know it's probably repaired I can't I
have no scrap guys zero scrap guys I
zero zero scrap
there is no scrap no there is no scrap
guys guys guys listen guys listen listen
listen you see you see you see this
number what this number what that mean
what that mean
what what it mean what it mean
what what it mean
it may not know what mean you only you
can tell me no what it mean
what mean
no this crap is too loud
it's not what it is oh
what
y'all got any scrap
hello
anybody here
oh one scrap
is there just scrap lying around
everywhere that I could probably find
maybe okay this is gonna help all right
one two oh man that oh that's not very
much all right but hopefully that's
enough to get us going
maybe we'll see
all right
a little bit zippier not much
be paranoid
zoom in on my map
why
did this help is everyone happier
did you know this game was made by just
one dude or one person I have no idea
they're very impressive I like it it's
got quite a bit of Polish
it's intimidating
oh
hello
hello
I don't know what's going on why did it
get really ominous all of a sudden hey
that's a box I like that
I like that
crap please yes
thank you
all right good good good good okay now
let's Endeavor did not let us get down
again let's Endeavor to be much much
better about everything in this game
that we've done so far so far hi can I
have that don't shoot me don't do it
don't do it
Myers are just drawn to the patch on
your pants I'm not looking down Gene
told us we'd have a newcomer soon I
suppose that would be you you'd probably
suppose right there's some scrap metal
in the balcony room of my house that you
could use to repair and upgrade your
train okay here's the case and although
the balcony is right behind me I'll just
mark it on your map anyway okay thank
you yeah baby's third Quest we don't
talk to anyone around here and uh
they'll do whatever they can to help why
anyone not wearing a mask that is okay
why check out the balcony and take
whatever you can use you're really
talking up this bill with everything
I don't know if I trust his balcony
I don't know if I I don't know if I'd I
don't know if I trust this balcony guys
I guys I'm gonna be honest
when someone emphasizes a balcony that
hard
I kind of start to suspect that balcony
just a little bit
okay
how good is this balcony
pretty good huh oh
a lot of scrap a lot of flies
we've been waiting as patiently as we
can but the past few days have been
chaotic to say the least Charles has
been more aggressive lately to the point
where I'm starting to fear how many of
us will be left by the time help arrives
godspeed Eugene we're counting on you or
you could leave the island I guess
I don't know if that's an option oh
thanks
I did it I got oh I did it I got him
okay good duck hey uh don't die
we got any fuel for this thing okay
we're full up repaired and our armor is
engaged I probably should have
saved some of that for repairs later
but I didn't
but I didn't
okay where are we going
a couple more people here required
mission
required inspired that's what I always
say
don't tell me what to do and I won't
tell you what to do
y'all got any scrap thank you
anymore thank you
thank you
huh
is that locked or something
okay
all right
is there a point to this
I feel like all of this metal you know
the scrap metal that's just jutting out
of the ground would be scrapped that I
could pick up you know considering it's
metal and scrap
but whatever what do I know
I just got here I don't know the rules
of the island
hello
hello is anybody here I thought there
was an NPC here
hello
hello oh hi look Ken I know you're
supposed to be some Fancy Pants Monster
Hunter but you can't earn my respect
without making yourself useful I just
met you what a Lawrence goons dumped a
lot just in the yard last night after
beating on it for a few hours I didn't
break anything but a sweat
I got some lock picks but I don't know
how to use them
here take them if you can get that chest
open you'll earn my respect I might just
give you some scraps to help improve
your train
okay cool thank you very much uh I I I
guess I guess also I do see that people
are getting super chats thank you very
much for that but also I always
encourage you guys to give those super
chats to smaller streamers and people
that actually do need it like I said
in the past I am more than fine don't
worry about trying to support me in
those means I appreciate it but at the
same time
like there are so many people that
deserve it more than I do I am gamer of
the year and I hereby decree that wow
that's tight timing
bam boom oh come on man my gamer the
year title is really slipping away from
me guys
oh and now and now now and now now all
right and now and now and now and then
I'm gonna now and now and then now
oh man
it's uh drawing
it's a drawing I got a drawing Daryl I
got a drawing you respect me yeah fancy
Fingers here got the chest unlocked yeah
I did
yeah
that's an odd looking piece of junk you
found inside there yeah let down to be
frank
you earned my respect so here's some
scraps like I promised yep
thank you
thank you is my mic peeking God I got a
new computer I don't have any of the
settings
oh is it am I too loud now am I too loud
hello guys
I'm sorry did I get extra scrap I don't
know
it's fine it's probably fine just when I
yell I bet
all speed all speed baby all speed all
speed
oh so much speed everybody
oh so much speed all right who is this
why is there right here hold on whoa
whoa Too Fast Too Fast all right we got
this hi who are you the Monster Hunter
has arrived I see yes I have this is no
ordinary hunt mind you we've already
tried fighting Charles but he Retreats
Into the Wilderness if he is
sufficiently harmed
we believe there may be a way to get
Charles to commit to a mortal battle
however a mortal battle dispersed around
the island are three eggs locked in the
Island's three primary mines
our theory is that putting these eggs in
the temple at the center of the island
will provoke Charles into a fight to the
death why why do you believe
unfortunately the mining company owner
warned Charles III has placed armed
guards inside each mine to protect the
eggs eggs train there's an egg in the
mine just down the rail
here's the key to the mine
right
um I don't have a gun
I don't I don't have a gun but maybe you
do maybe that person over there has a
gun do you guys thank you you got any
more
got any more of that scrap metal
got any more
hey thank you thank you very much for
the ominous advice I didn't win any
ah all right I'm gonna go now
I'm gonna go now
and then I'm gonna stop immediately give
me a gun oh this looks like a compound
hey I'm on a barge in
Lulu
[Music]
nice shirt I made a little flamethrower
as an addition to my spider train Home
Defense plan but as you can see it is
slightly uh backfired okay
nearly cooked myself alive in that shed
as I was testing it shoot dang shoot
dang I would love to save the shed
though
if a flamethrower somehow still works
after the fire dies down well you can
take it
I'd assume you're the monster hunter
that folks have been expecting so uh a
weapon like this could come in handy
I suppose you're right a weapon like
that could come in handy
um but do you have like a gun like a
like a gun you have anything gun-esque
you know because there's other people
with guns here that are shooting me with
bullets and not fires oh oh
oh that hurts so bad
well they are so bad it was so bad
what am I doing I
find a way to extinguish the fire
I don't I I don't how how would oh wait
a minute wait a minute wait
hold on
oh I'm so smart
oh gamer of the year of the year
that's me what is this on
orange I'd be down with orange uh do you
have it using the water tank to put out
the fire pure genius yeah genius yep
uh-huh
here take old bug spray cause of this
chaos I don't want to see it anywhere
near here again shoot dang
all right
okay
all right man who wants to bet that this
flamethrower is going to be way too loud
I bet I bet all right
whoa
ah oh
[Laughter]
ah okay so this doesn't exactly help me
with the um you know cultists but uh
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
I gotta go into the woods oh I'll be
right back guys I gotta go into the
woods I gotta run into the distance
put lies Beyond
why are you shooting shoot dang
big brain shoot dang too loud
and the old shootings are a little too
loud guys I'm sorry guys I can't I can't
can't control the shoot dang you know
what I mean yeah well hopefully oh my
God I have the most brittle bones God I
can't take even the tiniest little
hippity hop
man I think that I would be a little
better than that
I have started to do Callisto protocol I
just have not posted the first video I
was supposed to do it yesterday but I
got really sidetracked what with going
to the Emmys and thank Miss is this a
witch
are you a witch
God I don't mean to judge but really
you kind of talk like a witch I
you're fresh stew with ingredients for
my very own swamp but I don't have any
meat at the moment yeah
I smell a carcass on the island in the
swamp and if you wait over there and
bring it back for me I'll pay you some
scraps
although you'll need to be wary of berry
the swamp monster was that scripted to
do the lightning right when you said
that
I'm splashing around
and don't move if he gets close to you
as long as you stand still he's as kind
as a kitten
what
what what
swamp party salt Clover dirt salt meat
any kind salt
all right good guys I need you to watch
my back for Barry
oh God
it's like the amnesian water monster all
over again
why am I so splashy
oh
I thought this was gonna be a fun train
game
oh I made it I made it I made it okay
with carcass oh it's just a freaking
fish it's just it's just a fresh it's a
fresh fish
oh
good
oh what are we doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing Barry
oh
oh
and
oh
I'm gonna I think I'm making it I think
I'm good guys oh okay hey what's up hey
how you doing you a witch what a
delicacy you found thanks
are those scraps I offered thanks have a
safe night little one thanks
lightning
thanks can I have some soup all right
I'm gonna go where's my train I don't
even know anymore why did I come out
here what was the point of any of this I
regret every decision I've ever made in
my entire life
okay
all right
well anyway uh remember when this game
was just about fighting a train I want
to get back to that I never thought I'd
say that
um but I want to go punch a Terrain
let's all go kill a train guys
let's do it yeah we're gonna kill trains
whoa where's my train where is my drain
where's my train my train
okay oh there it is okay I thought that
I was gone there anyway shoot dang yeah
shoot dang that was a witch yeah man
Barry uh
Barry's a terrifying
anyway
um all right so I need to go get the egg
in the southern mine
uh what
what
try Orange
is good I like orange
hello
hello
mining's been proceeding smoothly and
we're seeing signs of a solid vein
already the tools are still holding up
well and we finished construction our
shelter we haven't spent long here but
we're getting settled in and adopting
good Rhythm and scheduled to our work
okay good
some people just love the mining life I
appreciate that
and the orange does look good damn
that's nice
uh-huh
okay
well this is the mine
the question is just where is the mine
entrance is this it okay is this uh am I
do I just go in I just go for it
I think I just go for it guys
pretty sure
feels like the most profound mind in
existence while mining the farthest
tunnel we broke through a wall into a
large Cavern there's something there
strange here and we don't know what it
is we're requesting that Mr Warren visit
the southern mine site Desi's earliest
convenience to give us further
instruction
okay
stealth
stealth stealth stealth stealth stealth
stealth stuff
what is that stealth stealth
stealth
self
there's no no
stealth stealth
stop stop
stuff stuff
I don't know what I'm trying to be
stealthy from
and I'm stealthy now uh and I'm now and
I'm now and I'm stealthy now
now and then also now
and then I'm stealthy now and now and
now that's how I do it hey green
nah
oh
stop stop
what am I hiding from stuff
I don't know what I'm having for
stuff
I can't even Crouch right now
there's someone here
weird Cavern though
Perfectly Natural uh constructions for
Perfectly Natural things such as
living trains
sure
someone whistling someone whistling
someone is whistling no
man thank you for whistling so goddamn
loud
it's just like he's whistling I Don't
Want to Be Free
I Don't Wanna Be Free
leave me in luxury
prison break when a hard time is totally
great
foreign
okay I think we're good well I have an
egg so that's good
get the get the gun get the what do you
mean there's a gun what do you mean
there's a gun what do you mean what do
you mean there's a gun how did all of
you see a gun and I didn't you guys are
living with the gift of foresight I
don't have that gift of foresight you
guys know just because you saw other
people lesser people than me I'm gamer
of the year how dare you watch anyone
else's videos but mine
I'm the only official gamer of this year
there's a gun in here no no this is what
people said the people said that there
was a gun in here and therefore I need
to go get the gun
I listen to what people say because I
the democratically elected gamer of the
year
knows what the people want
and therefore there is a gun somewhere
in here
the people with the gift of foresight
have granted me this insight and I will
not let it go to waste I do as the
people want
and I guess I'm just I guess there's no
gun
I guess there's no gun at all they must
have been lying which means that they
were probably lying about any other
place that could have a gun and
therefore I will not look very deeply in
any other location for a gun because I
know for a fact that there is no gun
because people were lying and because
people were lying
[Music]
I will never trust them ever again
I will never trust
is that
is that is it him
oh guys him is him it's him oh God it's
him is it him is it him
hey look a gun
well I can't have it
well that lot of good that did me
so I guess the the misunderstanding here
is that these guns weren't obtainable at
all anyway and that I you guys didn't
betray me by watching other YouTubers
other non-gamers of the year
oh
it was all a big misunderstanding let's
see what green looks like
you know that's not a bad green that's
not a bad green I do like it but I think
I like the orange better
it was all a misunderstanding guys God
that's hilarious anyway I have an egg
why I don't know
I don't know why I have an egg all right
but hopefully Mr Charles
doesn't come
a choo-chooing
oh
[Applause]
back that
was not uh
miss out on some goodies here
I bet those just randomly spawn
everywhere and that helps you keep your
uh
all speed baby all speed all speed
I love the speed I like the speed I love
the speed oh my God the speed look at
that speed oh
my God if only I had red paint that
would make this thing go even faster
everyone knows if you paint something
red it goes faster
always goes faster when it's painted red
everybody knows this everyone knows
anybody anyway all right so I now have
who I can do
the pickle Mission I'm really I'm far
away to do that on foot I'll probably
have to circle around for that one well
I suppose I might be able to make it
oh God yeah I'm gonna go for it I'm
going for it everybody this is probably
a terrible mistake this is probably the
worst mistake it's so far to go on foot
I am so exposed
but the lady wants her pickles
the lady wants her pickles and I gotta
go no red makes you go faster if I if I
paint myself red if I drench myself in
my own blood I would go so much faster
so true it hurts
everybody knows this
okay
is this where the pickle was supposed to
be
I don't like that beeping I think it's a
cricket now but it didn't sound like it
or told me
I feel so exposed
oh I don't like the wrestling got the
winds bustling
oh purple might be cool
God the wind is really hustling
okay
God it sounded like footsteps behind me
not like that
oh
well I got him
all right lady
um got your pickles I mean I I love
pickles too you know I'm not gonna judge
I like I like pickles
I don't like
um sweet pickles though
like I think that if you like sweet
pickles you're a weirdo and I'm not
afraid to say that a hundred percent
anyone that likes sweet pickles over
sour pickles
uh is bizarre is um incorrect actually
so uh I would judge and be very
suspicious of anyone that likes sweet
pickles
because it's just wrong and I I think
that they're just trying to
mess with you
because it's just too bizarre of an idea
here you go
okay
okay
the reward for your Valiant pickle
questing thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oh thank you thank you I gotta get back
to my train before something horrible
happens to me
anyway you enjoy those I'm the pickle
hero everybody
that's me
well
I guess I just
I deserve oh oh oh oh I've totally
forgotten that this game is about
fighting a train I've been so
sidetracked by everything else
okay purple oh
no thank you speed please speed please
oh God I need to change tracks wait oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
frick frick frick now now no go back go
back backwards
oh God oh God oh God forward forward
please please oh God oh my God oh my God
now oh there's an NPC here
this uh I I'm keeping it purple in honor
of uh Bob
speed's fully upgraded okay I guess I
have to upgrade other things but I'm not
[Music]
where is he where is it
hey hey
whoa whoa whoa no no no no no no no no
no
that's right I got speed on my side I
try I try yeah you back off Charles yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's what I thought
yeah no thank you
General thank you
no thank you
oh I'm too fast for him I'm too fast for
him oh God I hope I'm too bad for him
[Music]
oh God come on come on come on hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey I don't know if
I'd like the flamethrower
[Music]
come on
oh my God how long does he just stick on
how long does he just stay on you
[Music]
I wish I had the other gun I'm gonna try
to change out guns mid-fight
there's a terrible idea terrible idea
terrible idea I'm doing it oh
never mind I win
no never never
where am I
wait no I'm a backup no wait a minute oh
how what
what
how
oh man I went around uh oh
okay maybe uh god
um
okay well uh
oh flamethrower helps in slowing him
down well whatever I'm so fast I don't
think it's gonna be a concern
um I'm gonna go here and I bet if I'm
more stealthy then I can get by him yeah
so I got this
either way I win
I win
that train ain't so bad
that train ain't nothing
that train ain't nothing
I train ain't nothing
this job big scaredy train
I'm too good for that train incredible
actually man
that's why they made me gamer of the
year
[Laughter]
if you don't think that's going to my
head then you're horrifically wrong you
know my Eagle can't handle anything it's
a good thing I didn't win the Emmy
actually because if I if I did man that
would have been game over for me
I would have never recovered from it
ow
ow
where is he
stealth
where is he
oh there he is
okay so he's going some some sort of
some sort of triangle pattern
okay
was it in here yeah
[Music]
easy easy Theodore
Theodore
nice although I got a circle round
anyway so I'll just maybe I'll just back
the train up maybe I'll just back that
ass up
would it be any difference in speed if I
was going backwards or forward
right
where's my train
I'll just back it up it up I'll just go
backwards
I'll just go backwards
we're not hiding we're not hiding we
were just sneaking
we're stealthing it's very different
yeah
absolutely
where's my train
it's bright purple you think I'd be able
to see it
hello
hello anybody
hello anybody is anybody there yes
oh also I forgot to mention because I
was busy with um getting my Nudes on
only fans and then um
the Emmys and thank Miss uh I forgot
that there's a new cloak drop uh if you
didn't know cloak I am the only CEO of
cloak uh Soul CEO and uh there's no one
else that is in charge uh I just
everyone already knows that already I
just wanted to say that out loud there's
absolutely no one that is another part
of cloak it is just me and I am the CEO
where this is not correct where am I
going
oh yeah no this is fine
oh is that that big Temple
um yeah so if you want some uh new uh
Custom Clothes
along with a new custom version of the
cardigan that I love and wear all the
time you can find that through the link
in the description below uh for cloak
the company that I'm the only CEO
of
and I think we all know that and I don't
think there's any questions about that
whatsoever so glad I could clear all
that up I'll come back to Theodore in a
bit I'm gonna go see who this is
actually what I'll do is I'll back up to
this Junction that way I know where I'm
gonna need to go
huh I don't know what you're talking
about oh ah you're talking about oh
right um the janitor yeah uh
let's just say that we we put
Jack as you call him uh Sean into a
position that is more suitable to his
man it'd be so weird to call it a skill
set but I'll say uh his skill set
um so we found uh something that would
be
challenging for him uh and so he's he's
uh he's no longer in a position where he
can do any further damage
um yeah even though he has somehow
managed to find a way to damage
everything as janitor but it really does
suit his
unique methods okay all right good but
yeah you can uh check it out Link in the
description a new drop for cloak
cloakbrand.com great comfortable closing
I was supposed to get a package with the
clothing
um but Sean was in charge of that uh and
he neglected to send me any so I
actually don't have it on me usually I
would and uh this just goes to show why
we made the decision we did decide Birds
uh so anyway glad we could clear all
that up I don't think there'll be any
questions about it and honestly I won't
be taking any questions about it uh
given that I am now the uh or I always
have them really if you think about it
uh the soul CEO of cloak
thank you so much
as you complain to the CEO trust me if I
could I would but you know I've got so
many responsibilities on my plane anyway
that
oh I can't burden myself with more
it's tough stuff being the
only CEO the only CEO absolutely the
other CEO Soul CEO
that's fine it's fine
fine
it's fine
anyway Link in the description if you
want that
there we go
I don't know why I know to climb this
this is my gamer instincts telling me
that I must and so I do
hello at least there's some scrap but I
have a funny feeling that I was probably
supposed to meet someone here oh hi God
damn I'm great
oh hello
weird
setting the foundation for this
operation has been considerably more
complicated than I expected not only by
cost but the logistics of construction
and delivery of the supplies to the
primary mine sites we'll need to strike
gold fast if we want any chance to avoid
bankruptcy yeah always best to bank your
entire company's future on uh striking
gold
much like uh
Jack's uh quote-unquote leadership that
he uh exerts yeah
more like he he wields it like a like a
bludgeon to really just smack people
over the head with it what is this
critical item return to Ronnie to
complete your mission who's Ronnie
what
oh I started Ronnie run
Ronnie Ron what are you doing down there
run
Ronson
run
warning
run why didn't you say hi to me Ron
you can see why you looked like a monkey
climbing those Towers
I sure am glad I found these files
here's that scrap you were begging for
don't spend it all in one place
I should have looked at whatever what
was it I your everyone you're totally
right I should have looked at it and I
didn't I don't know why
but I didn't all right Ronnie uh good
meeting you I think I don't know what
the hell that was about but I'm gonna
leave now it was nice meeting you
and take care and fare well fair fair
care and take well
oh god oh no wait no no no no no no no
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no Charlie
Charles
Charles
don't do that don't do that
don't do that Charles where's my drain
where's my train
it's fine everybody it's fine
100 fine
okay we're currently at the junction we
could go back up this way Circle up here
hit those I think that's probably the
best move
well I guess I could get closer I don't
know why I felt like I need to walk
everywhere I do have a train after all
whoops damn it
wait which way was it oh it already was
whoa
yep it was already pointed this way
let's just go let's pretend that I
actually knew how to do it
okay
[Music]
this is important
is this important what is this we tried
and we failed by the time we managed to
clear the wreckage everyone had already
passed I'm sad and truly distraught I
thought of these men like brothers
causing these circumstances to cut
deeper than I could have imagined what
happened it's the other mind
[Music]
I don't even know if I have a key for
this aren't I supposed to have a key for
this
oh never mind
uh oh
okay well that that ain't happening
um
super sad about all that I don't know
what I'm supposed to think of it but uh
I'm gonna go now
this whole train situation was getting
to me uh
uh I guess damage right damage
fully upgraded okay so if I go up this
way there's only one two three four five
six uh I'll get these three because
they're required quote unquote
that'll help
and then all in all it should be smooth
sailing to get to uh
wherever these other eggs are and then I
kill Charles
for good
I think
okay cool
yeah what's going on I'm playing choo
choo Charles
and I'm talking about the various
Oddities of being a YouTuber and then
going to the Emmys which is a very
strange experience I I have to say so
whereby we lost the Emmy
for interactive media
which is fine
I'm not bitter at all
what is this a little bit here
so what's the point of this
I don't know how many landmarks are here
just floating around is nothingness and
what's actually important let me just
get to the um out let me get to the NPCs
because I bet if I go to them first
instead of just trying to explore
everything I'm gonna actually get some
answers out of this
but probably
[Music]
this doesn't seem good
I don't know if those Banners are
indicative of like one of those scrap
but whatever indicative of people that
are loyal to the
other causes
I do not know
hello well this looks like a lovely
piece how you doing a rare Iranian
municipal building
is this a municipality
do you actually have enough people for
that did you used to wow lovely place
is anybody home
nice explosives anybody home
anybody home I've been staking out this
area for days and Charles has never
crossed the old Wood Bridge somehow that
Beast is cunning enough to know it's
dangerous but if he's angry and
desperate he might just Chase someone
across it then bam we use John's Bomb to
blow the whole thing up in Charles Falls
face first into the canyon if the blast
doesn't kill him the fall surely will
I'm guessing that didn't work
or something tells me it wouldn't work
anyway hi how you doing you're the
archivist my father told me about oh it
was your your Eugene's son
although I'm disappointed to see that he
chose to stay on the mainland rather
than return with you
not to say that your help isn't
appreciated but we could have used his
Aid as well I already heard from the
others the Mind boss Warren is
protecting dangerous monster eggs that
could lead to catastrophe
while our main plan is to summon Charles
into a duel and fight him to the death
we've devised a perfect trap as a
precaution that may help defeat him aha
go attach these remote explosives to
each of the support pillars under the
Wood Bridge out there then meet me back
here okay all right interesting
fascinating even
so
your dad is
um
did your dad breathe when you knew him
like did your dad like walking
he's not doing that now
yeah you understand
ow you get it you get it you get it you
understand that yeah you get it yeah
yeah you get it uh this bridge this
bridge here are you talking about this
bridge to this bridge man I think there
was a Red Dead Redemption
um
just like this
some Advanced songs here
all right I did it
you who's gonna be bait
who's gonna be bait man
who's good who's gonna be bathed
who's who's bait
who's made
who's the debate man who's Paul who's
bait who's gonna be bait
Paul
Paul who's the date that's the tallest
and weakest bridge on the island so if
Charles ever crosses it we can blow him
Sky High okay I'll be on standby to
detonate the charges but it's still up
to you to summon and fight him here take
this it's the key to the temple once you
think you're prepared enough you can
break in and fight the Battle of a
lifetime
those were two completely conflicting
ideas do I fight him on the bridge or do
I take them to the temple and threaten
him with eggs
well I mean I put the bombs here so I
guess I'm gonna at least try nope
I'm gonna at least try ow
might as well right
I'm sure this is going to work just fine
so
I'll use the horn
to summon him and if he shows up behind
me I go forward if he shows up in front
of me then it's all good he just Falls
right
right
yeah this is a good idea
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
no horn yet no I don't think you know
what you're talking about how could you
know what you're talking about this game
literally just came out and if you're
here watching me play it
you definitely haven't watched it before
this has got to be the right answer when
someone tells you to put bombs on a
bridge
and you says you gotta get it over there
that's the mission
that's the mission
oh Charles I'm a sexy train in heat
you gotta make more eggs
come on Charles you know you want it
oh
no
[Applause]
damn it I don't think he's coming
I don't think he's coming
I don't think he's coming
I thought that was good someone just
saying no Mark and heat shoot
that's hilarious oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
so the fabled hunter has finally arrived
uh-huh
yeah you know my late husband built a
gun to help fight Charles but Warren's
goon stole the barrels and took him up
to their Camp Bob was such a brave man
much braver and you I bet well all right
that's a little rude if you take what I
have left to the gun and steal back
those other parts you can put it back
together to use against charm okay just
do me one favor William get Brave if you
do end up using it name it Bob in memory
of my honey well that's funny because I
think the whole train is now being named
Bob as we speak
so uh thanks I'll try to be a little
braver but you know I'm only me and
obviously I'm never going to be as Brave
as your late very dead husband
you know the one that died
the Dead one yeah I'll never be as Brave
as your dead dead husband
where was I supposed to go for that
it's so far away
that's closer
there's one more here wait stop no no
hello
the archivist and all your radiant Glory
why do you have so much blood there's a
lot of blood everywhere Colin trusted me
with a key to one of the mines
containing an egg but before I give it
to you I have to warn you about
something uh-huh there's an ancient
Shrine on the island pyramid of sorts of
curious prism located at the top uh-huh
the prism seems to have been designed
for one purpose to destroy Monster X got
a lot of blood three slots are carved
into the prism which perfectly fit the
eggs blood when fully loaded a massive
beam of energy is emitted seemingly
drawn from the eggs themselves blood
the millionaires hope this event will
lure Charles to a mortal fight as he
comes in defense of the eggs well
now for the real warning Charles has the
ability to absorb energy from the burst
strengthening and enraging him
we saw it once before and he may become
even more dangerous this time however
it's not my place to oppose despite the
danger so here's the Mind key once you
have retrieved all the eggs and the key
to the Shrine we might just be able to
end this hell
that was so much information
um do you mind if I read your diary at
last night's meeting Greg told us a
crazy conspiracy about Warren trying to
use spider trains for world domination
as part of the crew that worked in the
temple I'm far from convinced while the
prism was extracting the life energy
from a batch of eggs Charles attacked us
for the first time not only did he fight
like hell while the eggs were being
destroyed but he nearly doubled in size
as he fought as if he were consuming the
energy his legs grew larger and stronger
his face grew more distorted right
before our eyes those of us who survived
couldn't even fathom what we witnessed
that was when Warren hid the eggs and
ordered us to protect them that was when
he began evacuating people that was when
everything turned for the worst
hey
hey
what
where what
where is he
[Music]
hey hey hey hey
okay
that's what you get see his weapons so
much better
you can't let it overheat
okay
oh God oh God oh God oh God no no no no
no no no no no
no
no
no
no
that's what you get that's what you get
that's what you get okay stop
where am I
whoo
all right
um so that was nice we need to go back
around anyway and then I we'll just
carry on we're fast enough anyway okay
so I like that gun a lot better let's
see if we can make it better
a little better
okay
and armor I guess okay
so far so good seems like we got a good
handle on Charles but we're going to
need a better weapon to be able to
finish him off for good once we get the
temple all whatever and we get the eggs
all whatever then we're gonna lure him
into a final battle where we're gonna
send him careening over a bridge and die
I think I don't know why we couldn't do
that from the get-go but apparently I'm
not allowed
for some reason
I'm gonna Circle back around there was
I did the blue car I need to drop that
off there I'll probably swing by up here
back up and then go here
let's go for that
I think this should be still set to go
left here so I should be fine
so how are all you doing
have you uh how many of you have
subscribed to my only fans of which
there are more drops coming I just
haven't had time to edit the pictures
it's a trick question because I can I
wanna I wanna I'm gonna expose people
right now
I suppose people I'm exposed people okay
because you know what
I'm going to tell you straight up
I'm gonna tell you straight up
there were more individual people
that subscribe to my only fans
than any other
merch drop
cloak drop
live stream for charity more individual
people
subscribe to my only fans
then any single event prior that I've
ever done in my entire YouTube career
maybe even combined
more of you
shelled out
real dollars and it wasn't even high
quantity of dollars but it was three
dollars and you know how many times
we've done charity streams where we're
like guys please donate a dollar to
charity to feed the hungry to research
towards cancer more of you
opened up your wallets to buy my
tasteful news
than in any other event I've ever done
ever
okay
I haven't checked the number let me the
number is so astonishing
I mean
this is worth this is worth it let me
pull this up here
new number
okay I'm going
okay all right
okay
all right so to put it in perspective
like if if I did like a merch drop you
know there could be anywhere from
individually like five thousand to ten
thousand people would buy something
that's great
um
the number of people and in a charity
stream you know the number of
individuals could be like ten thousand
to twenty thousand people so many people
willing to help out that's incredible
even if the like the average generation
high low big donation that number of
people incredible
the number of people that made an only
fans purchase right now
with just one post
a hundred and twenty one thousand seven
hundred and eleven people
more people that are currently here
watching the stream live of which there
are 95 7 000 concurrent viewers
purchased
my
that is
that is
astonishing
shooting indeed
that is so
astonishing
it's almost frightening and I still have
more drops to do for only fans
it makes me realize that wow I should
have set the dollar price higher
for those more money would have gone to
charity
you thirsty Gremlins you
cause wow
oh no no no I'm not trying to say your
disappointments you're not
disappointments you really came through
because it is going to the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital and the world food
program and that is incredible and I'm
very grateful that you are helping out
this wonderful causes
and at the same time I can still be
incredibly disappointed but I'm not
saying I am
saying that could be exact box I needed
good now take these scraps and skedaddle
I'll screw you too you Wilfred wolf
stash wannabe you think that you are
Posh enough to stand up against me I
think not
I never thought in my life
I won't start now all right my own back
and I'm gonna go to the right and then
I'll get there anyway I just wanted to I
just wanted to say that out loud there's
been many many things that have occurred
over the past few weeks
um and it's like I haven't had time to
address all of them so I kind of like
get to them in streams and one on
whenever I'm just able to talk about
this [ __ ] uh as we're closing out the
year it has been quite a year it has
been pretty incredible the number of
things that have happening and also it's
pretty incredible that it's here already
the end of the year that is fascinating
we're almost through 22 and then we'll
be into 23 and everyone will still be
like oh maybe this year is going to be
better maybe this year is going to be
great
and there are many reasons that 2022 was
not great I guess some that it was great
I guess it really just depends on your
perspective right anyway
why am I waxing poetic while I'm talking
about only for the blood talk about only
fans and playing choo choo Charles
unloading all the supplies has been an
incredibly eye-opening experience here
at the Port we've been working all day
every day we are tasked with unloading
the boat and running supplies up the
hill to the tracks where Theodore and
Eddie deliver them to the different
sites we'll be mining the sheer cost of
all this infrastructure is mind-blowing
with all the success Warren's Family is
at in this business I'm surprised he's
choosing to take such a risk here
yeah maybe something to do with spider
cranes
is war still around because kind of
seems like Warren might be uh trying to
protect people from what that last guy
was saying but I know it's all a matter
of perspective
who knows okay there's someone down here
on the docks
you didn't break the oath shoot dang oh
congratulations to you shoot dang well
that's really impressive of you
[Music]
why is this so whistly
hello oh hi how are you doing hello
where are you where are you going my
goodness
I simply cannot stay any longer this
island is too much for my nerves to
handle huh
I've brought all my belongings here so I
can leave immediately when a boat
arrives uh-huh although now that I think
about it I did forget my journal at home
could you bring it to me oh it's a
dangerous Journey for sure but you might
manage with that train of yours I'll
give you all the scrap metal ah okay
sure whatever you say
where is your home
where is your home
where would your home business your home
is it this easy I've been praying blah
blah blah this is not a home
this is not a home
why would this be a home
where is your home
but I don't have to come all the way
back here I don't need this crap who
needs this crap not me not me at all
not me at all
ah anyway
[Music]
I just have this weird sneaking
suspicion that I've missed something
here
well doesn't look like I have I see
nothing
there's absolutely nothing all right I'm
getting in the train bye everybody I'm
certain there was nothing else that I
needed there
good very good very good actually
nope back up
back up back back
back up
there was no paint there was no paint
there was no paint
there was no paint there's no paint
where is the paint where is the paint
everybody you guys see paint huh you
seeing paint I don't see paint there's
no paint
I don't see no paint where's this paint
you're talking about well it seems like
there's no paint there ain't no paint
here
no paint
well I don't know it was by the dock oh
okay it's by the dock you did that you
you broke my legs you did that you
caused that to occur you did that hey
look babe
huh
Gray
wow well it certainly wasn't red all of
you are so stupid can you even believe
that you don't know Gray from Red what
is wrong with you what's wrong with any
of you who wants a gray train anyway who
wants a gray train look at it look at
how boring this is
wow oh
oh my God it's oh oh so good worth going
back for oh yeah this is ass
comparatively I just want to wear it for
the shame of not getting it man I'm so
glad that everyone just decided to
derail the whole stream so that we could
talk about oh that gray paint that oh
you know so needed right and now now I
know what's gonna happen now what I know
it's gonna happen is all of you are
suddenly you're suddenly gonna go gray
is the best color you all are going to
be like gray has always been my favorite
color how dare you Markiplier
insult me and my favorite color I will
never forgive you Markiplier for being
so asinine to me and for me and by me
this is an insult not only to me but all
those that I know
who love the color gray just as much as
me and that's what you're going to say
see ah there it is there it is I called
it called it
I called it I called it I knew it
you don't have any actual preferences
you just you just shout out whatever you
think you like what do you think will
make me mad
possibly understand what would make me
angry
you can't possibly understand that I'm
Paul asked me to design a new weapon to
help you hunt Charles and using my
extensive demolitions experience I made
this rocket launcher
I've been wanting to see Warren's Empire
crumble for a long time so building this
puppy was a hell of an opportunity
now that you're here
I need a few minutes to remove some
safety features yes please well I'm
working on that why don't you bring that
box of Rocket ammunition back here from
inside the bunker down the rail
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'm stuck debating if Warren made us
bring our families to this hellhole so
that we'd never need to leave or to keep
information about it private either way
I want that man in noose Paul asked me
to sign a new monster
[Laughter]
what did you need a bunker what are you
talking about wow that's pretty far
um but I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna do that
but there's someone else to talk to you
before I do that just in case uh
hello Hi how are you
why are you preventing me from getting
what I need oh I'm sure Eugene told you
all about me so I need not introduce
myself
ah that name's Greg by the way and in
case you haven't heard already Warren
the Mind boss is keeping three monster
eggs locked away we're unsure why he
wants to protect the eggs if they hatch
they would surely turn into monstrous
creatures like Charles to prevent this
we need you to steal all three and use
them to bait Charles so we can destroy
him uh one one of the x is is in the
north mine uh here's here's the key to
the entrance okay thanks you seem very
important God you know a guy like Greg
his favorite color is gray definitely uh
I need to write this Theory down fast
before Warren finds out that I'm onto
his dirty plot my theory is that Mr
Warren warlord III is trying to hatch
and raise more of those eight-legged
Critters a whole Army for who knows what
purpose they found wholeness of those
eggs while clearing out debris from the
cave-in we also know that their heart is
diamonds completely indestructible
the miners spend months using the temple
prism to suck the energy out of all the
eggs but before they could destroy the
last three old man war and stop them
Warren must have realized how powerful
these things are and rather than protect
us from them wants to use them to take
over the world I'm on to you Warren yeah
this guy's favorite color is gray did
you know that
yep
seems like a real gray lover oh well at
least I have that now there's another
mine there okay so mine Journal
do I care do I care
I do I guess
hey why are you all alone out here in
the corner of nowhere
why do you make me run to you
why oh you're in a lighthouse ah that
does make sense
that makes sense that that makes a lot
of sense that does make sense
oh I missed another paint can paint cans
aren't real
why do you keep believing in paint it's
not real
it's just a myth made up to make
children behave that's all paint is it's
a fairy tale it doesn't exist I don't
know why you think that it exists at all
you need to grow up just like Santa
Claus is not real
are you okay we haven't met but I've
heard Lots about you coming to help us
you okay I have a favor to ask the
breakers on the side of the lighthouse
need replacing
I was recently attacked by Charles so
I'm unable to do it myself the breakers
are in the nearby Supply shed if you go
get them and repair the lighthouse I can
try signaling passing ships to come help
us oh once you finish I have some spare
scraps to give you I mean that is very
you are you okay
don't mind if I read this
charging my directions by train okay
um you okay
you you are you all right
are you all right you okay oh they're
right there oh that's fine
Oh I thought they were far away
oh I guess it's like your leg is
attacked
I guess you wouldn't be able to do that
okay
I'm actually glad I came down here
because I feel bad now I thought you
were just all alone in the in the what
about Santa oh Santa's real
oh yeah
tell me about what I said
Santa so real my God I'm amazing I did
it
you're welcome are you okay okay goodbye
anyway ah yeah yeah Santa's real yeah
yeah yeah yeah Santa's real just like
paint yeah okay there's like just like
the color gray yeah very real yeah okay
I bet you think your walls are painted
right I mean they are oh yeah they are
they're painted yeah I bet you when you
go to when you go to Home Depot there's
a whole aisle dedicated to paint oh wow
I bet yeah I bet it's just like oh so
many different selections that you can
choose from yeah you can get gallons of
the stuff just gallons of it yeah right
okay yeah and Santa comes down your
chimney and oh just squeezes his fat
body through the chimney and then
delivers presents to everybody in the
world yeah that's that's real yeah
that's believable yeah 100 oh yeah no I
believe it oh I believe it oh yeah
anyway carrying on
Lottery oh wait actually I just need to
stop here because I'm going to get the
break in and then I'm going to get a
rocket launcher
I just need to not be caught
I don't care what you say rocket
launcher is amazing in any game
if you have an option to get a rocket
launcher you get the rocket launcher
hello
huh
hello
okay not there
where what is it just in the center here
this seems dangerous
this seems horrifically wrong
is this a Minefield did I just walk
through a minefield
did I just successfully walk through a
minefield
and thank goodness all these quests are
literally within walking distance of
everything or else I would have to go
forever
yeah
think about the children Mark yeah oh
yeah yeah because yeah paint
's real yeah oh yeah yeah when your
parents when uh when they they made your
childhood bedroom they they painted it
your favorite color they did that uh
hello can I talk to you
hello
what
oh
ah I'm dumb
I'm very dumb right I'm dumb guys why
didn't you tell me I needed to use the
explosives to blow open the door why
didn't you say that guys God I wasted so
much time going back and forth if you
would have told me that I needed to use
the explosives here at the door I
wouldn't have wasted so much time
like why do you not want me to succeed
it's okay guys I'll forgive you this
time but really like next time just be
more aware like if
if you're not going to pay attention to
me playing these games why do I even do
I'm gonna die why do I even do this oh
come on guys
come on you gotta gotta support me
somehow
uh success
it's okay guys I I know they're probably
I get it there are people that are
actively trying to sabotage me and
that's understandable you know but if we
work together like we can we can build a
better experience for everybody
we can do that we will do that together
but you have to believe in me
and you have to tell me when I'm missing
something very important and vital
I forgive you
and I might forgive you another time but
a third time I will not
I think that's understandable
great
anyway I gotta get a rocket launcher I'm
gonna guess bloody can I have his bloody
working order so I'll let you take it
from here okay take good care of it I
won't after you're done I have a few
people to visit with it if you catch my
drift you're gonna blow people up with a
rocket launcher oh my God
oh whatever
to each their own
where is my dream we're getting close to
the end here because what I got to do is
I gotta go in and then immediately get
the two eggs go to the temple because I
have all the things that I need right
oh my God I better not miss ooh I like
it oh god oh
hello
wait wait wait wait wait wait
all right okay all right oh yeah what do
you think of that yeah you didn't like
that did you what about that oh you
don't like this do ya oh no besides that
goes oh it hurts me wait it hurts my
train wait this is a terrible idea wait
who thought this was a good idea who who
thought this was good who who thought
this was good
who thought oh were you running you
running
you running yeah you run a dog he's
doing a run with me we're running
together oh this is cute
that's cute okay rocket launcher again
not as good as I thought it might be
thought it was gonna be amazing
man that's so many optional things
um
oh I'm here I've met literally every
other NPC I'm just gonna go for it
I've done every other NPC at this point
I've got to be completionist about it
because there might be something else
yeah I know I know I know I can switch
out guns mid fight I've already done
that if you were here before you would
have seen a totally radical me doing
that exact thing but you didn't so it's
fine whatever
huh what like paint I don't know what
paint is I've never heard of paint don't
know what you're talking about hello
anybody here no
okay weird hello oh Journal okay
I can't read it
okay so I have that but there's no
guarantee I'm actually gonna take that
back to him so
you know to use their own
whatever that means okay weird alter
don't know what that's about maybe this
NBC is going to tell me what this weird
altar is all about
hello
hey do you have any paint in here
you got any paint
I haven't gotten new paint in a while so
I'm gonna agent for it
next time I found any more drawings 16
drawings multiple nights in a row
accompanied by horrific ghastly noises I
don't feel safe going out there again
what that doesn't have to do with it say
you're that monster hunter how do you
know of me I must know do you have any
experience with ghosts no someone or
something has been painting exactly 16
drawings to Lamppost in the Boulder
Field every night I always collect and
burn them but as I was looking for them
last night I began hearing strange
noises and seeing strange things I only
found half of them yesterday because of
the commotion could you go find the last
date and bring them to me
foreign
you want me to go into the woods and
find eight pages you want me to go
into the woods and find eight
pages
okay
[Music]
you want me to you want me to go into
the oh frick that oh shoot dang
oh no
oh boy
you do know there's a giant spider train
that is terrorizing everything
oh no no no
no
oh boy
I didn't I've never even beaten the
original game
I've never beaten the original game
never done it
whoa hey nice wow
hey
easy now
what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing
can you not do any of what you're doing
that'd be great
that'd be real great
very bloody
where am I
where am I
where am I
okay
ow
we continue where am I oh I'm back at
the beginning okay
oh
it seems like he just boots me out of
the area okay at least it's not instant
game over God I still would not beat uh
silence Pages you know the whole game
slylin pages I remember slyland pages
like it was yesterday uh
with the silent man
oh good times
also I don't have any clue where I got
Pages already so fumbling in the dark
oh
I don't know where they are
yo yo yo yep okay one more one more one
more one more one more one more one more
come on
I'm never gonna be able to find it whoa
dodging through the trees
I'm never gonna find it
nope
nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope oh
God nope
nope
nope
nope
I went past it what do you mean shoot
dang I
what do you mean I went past it
I did not
I did not
get out of your mind
where is it
[Music]
oh
oh
no I didn't no I didn't you know how I
know oh I got an award that says I'm
gamer of the year I'm sorry did I did I
misread that and they called your name
to be gamer of the year instead no they
called me to be gamer of the year and
therefore I am gamer until next year
when the next gamer of the year gets
elected and I got elected because I am
obviously the best gamer of the year and
therefore when you think that you can
challenge me for that title of gamer of
the year then you can meet me in the
gamer field of battle and we can duke it
out and then you can take it from me I
see it no no ah yeah got it
and so that's what I say about that
that's what makes me gamer of the Year
all right you come back to me when you
can do that as galaxiously as I did
okay I think
I think I've said enough
wow oh man I am incredible
he's gonna be me
thank you thank you
thank you for the recognition that I
definitely deserve and also in space
with markiplier with show of the year I
don't care what the Emmys say
I don't care
friendship with Emmy's ended Streamys is
my best friend thanks for bringing me
those papers you're welcome for your
help I wouldn't hold on to those papers
if I were you
would do I just get scraps for that is
that all again okay whatever
well now I've officially met every
single uh NPC and done every single side
quest possible and I have almost enough
scrap to completely upgrade my training
that hurt apparently
and now I can finally finish this game I
got to get on to the whole subject of uh
you know killing a train which is the
whole reason we're here in case you
forgot about that the whole reason we're
here is also for you to know about the
new cloak drop that just happened this
weekend why don't you go check it out at
cloakbrand.com Link in the description
where you can see all of the wonderful
options that I
the sole CEO of cloak have to offer you
I am the brains behind the operation
always have been always will be in I
mean we all know that I'm the face
behind it as well
brains and Beauty all in one package
that's what's deserving of being the
only CEO of that wonderful establishment
anyway Link in the description and uh
don't listen to anyone else when they
say anything about anyone else okay
let's go uh purloin some eggs
you guys know what purloin
oh oh God oh God oh God no not that way
no no wait
okay go oh God
was that actually it or was that just
the ambiance
because I gotta go in a cave soon
I kind of got to go on a curve
I gotta go in a cave
was that him I don't know if it was him
okay I'm gonna go
is this a bad time to go I feel like
this is a bad time to go
I feel like this might be a bad time to
go but
if I can get in a cave maybe I don't
think I can get into the cave
okay I'm not seeing anybody it must be
deeper in the cave
okay
let's do the thing
look at this egg
fun
so who built these temples
who built the temple that allowed these
spider trains to occur
where are you going
whatever feeling is it's going to come
back
what are you talking what hey hey whoa
oh whoa how you eagle-eyed bastard what
are you what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing where go back
go go go away what do you
huh
why hey wait wait why why why why why
why why why why why ow my bones why
would you do that
why would you do that don't do that
don't go away
go away can I kill you if I lure you to
my train which is very far away need I
remind you
if I lower you to my train can I blow
your ass away
with my rocket launcher or guns oh my
God I hope it's this way I think it was
this way was it this way I can't check
my map there it is I'm gonna I'm gonna
destroy you are you still there
out
I'm gonna blow your ass to Timbuktu well
that went over your head weird
can I whoa all right
that's what you get
that's what you get
asked what you get
that's what you get
anyway
man that guy was persistent that guy
didn't want to stop for nothing
that guy really really really wanted to
finish me off
but uh nuts to him I'm still alive and
he's extremely dead
anyway hopefully I don't have to do that
again you know it turns out they spot
you from a mile away instantaneously
it's not even a huh it's a huh
immediately pursue until the end of the
Earth
I have a funny feeling he would have
swam across the ocean to get me
all right one more and I got a stealth
I have to stealth
not doing that whole running thing again
where are you
I see you over there
what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing where are you
where'd he go
oh
there goes this way
interesting
interesting very interesting
oh very interesting where you going
where are you going
[Music]
fascinating
fascinating okay
I don't think he's gonna come back oh
may he might he might oh he might
oh he might
oh he might oh he might
okay we're good we're good he's gonna go
that way now
I'm gonna grab the egg
yep
there better not be another one of you
all I gotta say about this
there better not be another one of you
it better be egg and I get out of here
[Music]
oh God oh God wait oh God
oh God oh God no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I just want an egg give me
an egg hey look at that guy you don't
you don't mind if I you don't mind if I
do you mind if I do you mind if I you
don't mind if I you don't mind if I I'm
out you don't you don't mind if I you
know anybody
I don't mind if I I got very strong
bones you don't mind if I you don't mind
if I you don't mind if I yeah if I duck
and weave if I Bob even
oh you don't mind if I I went the wrong
way again oh you don't mind if I
you don't mind if I oh you don't mind if
I oh
how do
you how do you know
how did I not go the right way uh I feel
like
I feel like I was going the right way I
feel like I
I feel like I was going the very right
way
um
and yet it seemed like I wasn't going
the right way I was going the right way
and then they didn't
yep ow cause I was trying to get out and
um it wasn't doing the getting out you
know what I mean
I was like oh hell yeah I'm gonna get
out and then it didn't
got a new strategy
very bold variable no trip
very bold tragedy watch this
very bold
you don't mind if I
you don't mind if I you don't mind if I
all right they don't mind if I
all right
no that's
[Applause]
don't mind if I don't mind if I
we
don't mind if I okay so I'm I'm not
gonna mess this up because it's very
clear where I need to go it's here
and here and this is where it was this
is where this is where it was this is
that was that was where it was I'm not
crazy that that was where it was
you hope I'm what
you hope I'm what so
so what
but
but
so if so oh really
bye it's a different one
it's a different one
there's a lot of whistling going on what
it is
that's not cool that that's not I don't
even know where I am that's so uncool
why would you do that why why would you
do that they're gonna uh uh uh
uh okay um I don't know where I am and
they're D oh yeah okay I need to look oh
God no no no no complete wrong
okay I corrected my trajectory he's
screaming out here get him boy gotta get
em boys oh man I didn't know I was being
chased by nerds
all right boys okay all right hope he
doesn't have a rocket launcher boss oh
there's no way he's got rocket launcher
that'd be ridiculous okay boys he's
gonna get him let's go get him ah fine
why do I gotta run so far where even am
I this isn't the right area where am I
you still there oh not yet you're not
okay they're pretty far
okay well this is this is fantastic this
is fantastic I don't care look guys look
did you see an opportunity where I could
have gotten the red paint oh why do you
care so much it doesn't even matter it's
just paint we have and we've agreed on
The Bob train in honor of Bob so that
it's purple
and that makes us happy right we're all
happy for it I'm not gonna do the rocket
launcher they deserve to get burned
they'll be coming around the mountain
any second now
fine I don't care I'm out of here we all
agreed we all agreed that the purple was
the color that we were gonna go with it
doesn't matter about the red paint oh it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter about
the bread paint turns out oh it doesn't
matter
oh it doesn't matter about the red paint
because who cares
no one we're upgraded we're the whole
wow what the
hell yeah
hell yeah look oh oh
whoa we're upgraded
that's good I like that and you know
what else I'd like firing Rockets into
the uh mine before I have to go in two
soften up the target
I think I'll do that
hope this is someone
maybe just listen
yeah whatever fine
all right I'm going in
if there's paint anywhere
I don't care
I don't care about paint
hey who's whistling
oh you see me oh oh oh you see me oh
what oh come over oh no oh
that's a cool looking train guys not
gonna lie
cool looking drain
someone coming at me
did they
did they decide to no no did they
finally stop chasing
be here Asian mirror hey come on
you actually coming you better run yeah
I am running you better run is what I
gotta say
all right
there no
[Music]
oh oh frick
what if it doesn't notice
[Music]
I'm going in the cave I'm going the cave
I don't have time to fight that
to go in the cave and I'm gonna be just
fine where the cave is that's where I'm
going where's the cave everybody's seen
a cave cave
cave
where's Gabe Gabe there's cave okay
we're fine we're fine
we're fine
everything's fine we don't need to worry
about it
trains armored so even if Charles goes
at the train while we're away
it'll be fine
foreign
is this even something that I care about
it's not but whatever
oh
now
oh damn it now
now
then ah then then
oh
now now
oh my God how
now
Brown
cow cow
okay
hey blue paint oh awesome
that's sick
[Music]
Frick oh frick frick frick
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do I go this way
is this what I'm supposed to do
oh don't shoot me don't shoot me don't
you oh my God don't shoot me oh don't
shoot me don't do it don't do it you do
not want to do it oh God oh God wow okay
all right it's fine when you say like no
unauthorized allowed that it sounds like
it's like hey get out of here not I'm
gonna blow your brains out
so I mean you can see how I might be
mistaken about that
anyway we're good we're good guys we go
to the temple now we're done so we're
one zo and we're done so we kill Charles
we're done so
that's how this goes we're dunzo and
wanzo I'm not even gonna bother with
them
they get to live for some reason they
get to live so we just need to Circle
back around
[Music]
whoa whoa hey whoa whoa oh Rocket
Launcher not what I wanted okay it's
fine
I'm Gonna Change change it out one Buck
break
there we go there we go there we go oh
damn it
oh I didn't want to go across the bridge
did you oh scared oh you sound kind of
scared of that bridge huh oh cause you
know there's floaties all over it
all right
where are we at
so there's still this weapon that I
haven't gotten and there's still that
one that I haven't gotten but I don't
care
whoa oh what the how are you back you
were a scared baby you were a scared
baby what happened to you
you were scared
you're scared
seems like I'm getting scrap every time
I hit him this is awfully nice
[Music]
there you go that's right get out of
here all right I'm off Target I believe
yep
well actually no wait yes I need to go
back
all right and we got blue paint
that's not a bad blue
yeah that's not about blue
huh get Bob gun get the Bob gun what is
with you guys
get the Bob gun it's op
who cares see this is the this is I am
making all right I'm here
I'm making an official decree
as gamer of the year I want you to
listen to me very closely
when you say something
like get the Bob gun because it's op
why would that be a desirable outcome
why would it be desirable to get a
weapon that makes the entire experience
trivial
why would you intentionally ruin the fun
and the challenge of beating Charles at
his own game with a weapon that
trivializes the experience
you should be ashamed of yourself and
your desire to play it on easy mode
because that is only indicative that you
lack the skill to be able to beat
Charles whereas I have both the skill
and the will to be able to beat him not
only at his own game but my game
therefore I don't care what you have to
say and I will no longer listen to you
because I'm being attacked here I'm
being attacked
I'm being attacked
man if only I had a better gun
probably had a better gun take this all
of you wait I need to wait hold on no no
stop I got I need I really need to
ran someone over oh my god I didn't even
know that was possible hey
stop it
that's what you get
whoa these guys are persistent
now oh those
so no
I'm not gonna get the other weapon
because I don't want it
anyway that's it also I'm not a
completionist I don't I don't even care
about completing oh man I am in trouble
yeah since when it was I a completionist
well you know who I am
specifically I'm not a completionist
all right
it's time to finish it
well I guess it could
oh he's the only one I haven't oh man
oh but I don't want
all right
fine
fine I'd rather fine
but you're all gonna see why you would
why it's a bad idea you're all gonna see
I'm gonna get it now I'm never gonna use
it you think that just because I am this
close to being a completionist of this
game that has any influence on me no I
don't care what my audience wants I am
in the antithesis
of playing into whatever the hell you
want because you know what I don't care
I don't care it may seem like I'm caring
because I'm doing the thing that you
wanted but it's only because I've now
decided that I want it it's not about
you I'm not even gonna read that I don't
even care what that says
okay all right you hear me you hearing
me all right you better be hearing me I
got a key what did I get a key to
did I get a gear scrap look like a key
[Music]
you know what
I don't know why the music is stuck the
music is really stuck for some reason I
don't think it's gonna stop
the music has been like hyper dramatic
for way too long what a oh my God
oh my is that what their masks look like
oh my God
holy crap
oh that's awful
oh it's awful
oh I hate it
oh I hate it
huh
oh I did get a key oh
oh
I got Bob
I got Bob
I got Bob
all right oh God oh God oh my God
Oh I thought I saw it I thought I saw it
okay all right let's just assume Bob oh
Bob
[Music]
wait I think I need to kill that guy
because I think he's like the last one
oh never mind never never no that
go Bob go
okay it is very fitting that on the
Bob's purple train we do have Bob the
weapon this weapon is pretty dope but
again like I said
why trivialize it just because it's
great weapon it is this is a good weapon
okay I can
all right I'm feeling it yeah I I'm
feeling it
but I seem to be getting hit a lot so I
mean is it really that strong
I don't know if it's that strong guys it
seems to be getting hit all over the
place that day I don't know I'm pretty
pretty weak pretty weak Yes Man pretty
pretty weak did I get the journal I got
the journal right
pretty good weapon I guess
how far it was man do I have to go all
that way I wonder if I go forward and
backwards here if it'll go backwards
I got I got the yeah I got that yeah I
got the Bob gun yeah I got it yeah I got
it whatever
oh I got it
it's not even that good
damn it okay I gotta go all the way
around I have to go all the way around
to get to this guy that's how annoying
this is and it's all your fault I
I'm mad at all of you every one of you
every single one of you you know why
because in all this time
you haven't clicked the link in the
description below
so many more of you have clicked the
only fan stuff that have gone to
cloakbrand.com and even looked at the
stuff that we have there
ever experienced and you haven't even
looked at it after all you've put me
through after all the suggestions that
you've said in the comments over and
over and you haven't even looked in the
description
you haven't even looked and I know I can
see
I can see who clicks on the link
I'm the CEO
you
yeah my feelings don't matter anyways
[Music]
I know my feelings don't matter
this is fine it's whatever
I'm just trying to kill time because
it's taking a while I thought this was
speed where's my speed
come on
come on
yes oh thank you thank you for clicking
it thank you very much for clicking the
link I appreciate that that is very nice
of you that is very kind of you and I
love you for that and I appreciate you
for that I appreciate you for that
yeah we never got the red I don't know I
can't read the journal it doesn't even
let me I tried it didn't work thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much as the sole CEO of cloak I
take it as a a show of faith in my
leadership ability and a lack of faith
in every anyone else's leadership
ability that would even make a claim to
be the CEO
I don't know why you would though there
was no one else that ever would it's
just me
always has been anyway we're almost here
all right and three two ones
[Music]
all right probably from here I can just
take this over this way no matter what
I'm very likely going to have to
hoof it all the way around the island to
get back to the bridge
so this is going to be the last stop for
anything he's gonna give me enough scrap
to be able to keep my ship in ship shape
than the other Bob gun is too loud look
it's
I don't know what else to do about it
man I don't know what else to do about
it
I've tried to get the volume as perfect
as I could
I know where the red paint was I'm not
going back
you're welcome
I couldn't
um here are those craps I promise wait
could I have
I wait I looked at my inventory I
clicked on I was like I can't look at
that I could have read it
oh man
oh
all right I gotta start the whole game
over guys I gotta know what's in this
guy's Journal go
but I thought that oh man this is
I'm so sad
life
just gets me down
I can't believe it
can't believe it
tragedy
sad music is here for a very specific
reason is because I didn't read that
guy's Journal
God I bet it was really embarrassing too
I've had all of it was so incredibly
embarrassing
oh well
let's finish this fight
let's finish this
I can't read it okay okay
that's good to know I was about to be
devastated
but thankfully I can't agree
wow a temple
I'm going to charge in there blindly and
hope for the best true up there are no
enemies in there for uh me to shoot at
I thought I saw I did a Wham
yeah I don't notice this
got him
anybody else
I feel like this should leave explodies
but it don't
this will leave explodes though
anybody hit by that
that's good I'm going in
I'm gonna keep this on though
all right
you're done Charles you're done Charlie
oh my God wow
[Music]
oh
my God
oh my God
what
what
foreign
what all right
you're done Charles
I'm Gonna Get You
I'm uh you're done
don't even try to stop me
I've known oh God hello how are you
doing hey what's up all right let's go
Ring Around the Rosie a little bit wee
and then I'm gonna put some eggs in here
and it's gonna be super cool all right
easy
done and done
we don't want any more train babies
isn't this how Game of Thrones happened
man I wish I had hands
[Music]
step away from the shrine stranger you
don't know what you're doing just put
the egg down slowly and lay flat on the
ground
you'll hurt far too many people if you
follow through with whatever you're
planning
no
no
you fool
you don't control
[Music]
all right
hey my train
as convenient
all right let's go baby oh God okay you
you you get some of this hell Charles
I'll be overheated
but this isn't
yes
I hope I don't have to switch into
anything else
oh I missed I missed oh I missed what
oh wow
oh oh hello
what yeah what oh oh no
what what
I I don't know do you want fire
there we go
that's what you get
I'm gonna have to try to heal eventually
maybe in that oh wow no that's bad good
thing I'm armored
okay
flamethrower is pretty good not gonna
lie
one throws dope
whoa
I'm doing great
oh wow
ow
almost got him
[Music]
oh
it's the bridge
is the bridge oh
[Laughter]
oh man
that was awesome
thou sick
oh Gavin eisenberg's Gavin eisenbies oh
well done
well done
what a lovely game
what a lovely game what a lovely lovely
lovely lovely game I want to talk about
an injustice that I saw before I started
playing this which was that IGN and you
never rely on IGN's reviews of anything
ever right
you would not believe the score they
gave this game
they gave this game a 4 out of 10.
they raided this game that you just saw
a four out of 10.
and I'm like I've played so many Indie
Games I've played so many indie games
this had Great Moments great atmosphere
it was fun it had moments to dragged
sure and it had like things that were
unpause it was made by one guy
this was great oh
ominous
I know a four
like I'd understand being like Oh you
know it's a little rough around the
edges so I'd had some time to drag like
maybe a i if they were like seven and a
half I'd be like all right sure yeah no
it's not a perfect game oh frick
oh frick
oh oh that's
yeah I know a four a four
a four and whatever
anyway that's why I like
that's why I know it's tough reviewing
games and giving them a score that's why
I like I don't give score just don't
give scores who cares about scores
anymore no one cares about scores look
at mine look at my goddamn train even
better than choo choo Charles look at my
train that game was great I love that I
think that's super fun I had a great
time doing that I had a great time
playing that I bet you had a great time
watching that despite all the antagonism
going back and forth we had a great time
playing together so thank you everybody
so much for joining me on this wonderful
Adventure support the developer go play
this for yourselves I didn't completion
ate anything but I bet you did and I bet
you won't experience the thrill of
running away from a train while you're
on a train yourself shooting in a train
because that was pretty fun that part of
the game really really solid I enjoyed
that a lot thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the link in the
description below for cloak Brand's
newest quilted cloak drop it's the most
comfortable stuff you'd ever wear I know
I don't have it on me right now because
because I didn't get it in time for the
drop and I was busy with other things
but trust me I was in the process of
making it so I know exactly what I'm
talking about I'm the CEO after all the
only one don't trust anyone else you
ever hear about that the only one
thank you have a lovely day
and uh thanks so much for being here and
believing in me even though we didn't
get the Emmy we still got the streamies
and I as gamer of the year
will stand by the Excellence that the
team that made in space with markiplier
put into it
thank you
yeah yeah more of the other games are
coming soon I gotta go and record him
and live my life and get some food
because I'm very hungry so thank you
have a lovely day goodbye everybody I'm
out of here take care bye
shoot dang
goodbye